ALEXIS MP: So hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
Today, the topic is
Docker-- in the cloud,
on the desktop,
Docker everywhere.
And I'm speaking
with David today.
So what do you want
to show us today?
DAVID GAGEOT: I'd
like to show you
how easy it is to package
a Java 8 application, a web
application, on your laptop with
Docker, and use this package
application to deploy
it on that platform.
ALEXIS MP: So what we're
trying to demonstrate here
is the fact that you're able
to build an environment which
will be running on your
development environment,
and use the exact same
environment, packaged
as a container, with
the Docker technology,
and ship this across to
the cloud and computer.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yes.
It is exactly like
a big binary file.
But inside this binary,
there's your application.
There's also all
the dependencies.
The Java 8 version,
the operating system.
Everything is fixed,
and you can run it
on the machine or the cloud
with the same command.
ALEXIS MP: Sounds
promising, I think.
It's quite useful.
Why is it actually useful to
have this same environment
across--
DAVID GAGEOT: It
works on my machine.
It doesn't work on production,
it works on my machine.
So this is one of the reasons
why Docker is very useful.
You can reproduce exactly
the same environment
on your machine
as on production.
It's especially very important
if in operation, you've
got multiple servers, load
balancer, different components.
So you can reproduce
exactly the same environment
on your machine with
different containers.
You could do it with VMs,
but then on your machine,
you would run lots of VMs.
It would be too much
for your machine.
With containers, it's
very lightweight.
Very easy.
ALEXIS MP: OK.
Let's get going and
let's look at the demo
you have prepared for us.
DAVID GAGEOT: OK, so I've
prepared a very small project
with a single file
called Dockerfile.
This Dockerfile is the
recipe to build my container.
So I will show you the
Dockerfile very quickly,
and then we'll run it, and we'll
come back to the Dockerfile
to see what it contains.
Let's create the container
from this Dockerfile.
It's like a recipe
to make a cake.
So that's build a cake.
Here it is.
It will download lots
of things, install
lots of things
inside the container.
Let's take a look
at the Dockerfile.
So what I'm saying is my
container is based on Ubunto.
And then I will install lots
of components, mainly Java 8.
I will install Maven, Git.
Then I will clone the
source code of my project,
build it inside the
container to be sure
that the build is
easy to reproduce.
And what is very important
is at the end of the build,
I've got classical
Maven install.
Here's the command that
the container will run.
So classical Java application.
ALEXIS MP: So it is
definitely a recipe.
You are building
everything from zero.
So hopefully the recipe will
always produce the same cake.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yes.
Not always.
In fact, if I run the
same recipe in two weeks,
the version of each
components might change.
So I could fix the
versions inside my recipe.
But then, at the end
of the day, Docker
is not really based on you
running the same recipe again
and again.
You run the recipe
once, and then you've
got a binary that you
can run on your machine
or run on another machine.
ALEXIS MP: And there
are ways to share
this with different
people, if you-- even
a common repository
for people to use.
DAVID GAGEOT: Exactly, you can.
It's like a battery.
So you can copy it,
or you can publish it
in public or private
repositories.
There's lots of ways to
share container images.
What we will do is we
will use the recipe
to build locally and build
on the cloud platform.
It's not the thing
you will do normally,
but it's just to
show you that it's
the same locally and
on the cloud platform.
ALEXIS MP: Great.
So it takes a few minutes to
build locally on the laptop,
so we'll just skip
ahead and get to a point
where we're about
to finish the build.
DAVID GAGEOT: So here we are.
We're running the
last Maven build.
And at the end, it will produce
the Java flies that we need.
And we'll be able to
launch the container
and see if the
application runs properly.
ALEXIS MP: Great.
So tests are going.
And as soon as the tests pass,
I suppose you have-- no tests.
Wait.
DAVID GAGEOT: It's not me.
Yes.
Here it is.
So build success, and then
the container is ready.
What I want to show-- you said,
can we use the same respect
to build a container twice?
Docker uses a cache to make sure
that, if on the same machine
you build from the same
recipe, it will use cache
again and again
so that you don't
run all the steps of your
recipe again and again.
So you should
change an operation
at the end of your
recipe, it will
reuse the cache for all the
operations before the change.
So let's try to
run our container.
What we are going to do is to
ask for the version of Java
inside the container.
ALEXIS MP: Just to make sure
we're using the right one.
That's one thing you
can try to check.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yes, to make
sure that it works properly.
So we saw the Docker
build an operation,
so now we're going to
use the Docker run.
So we run the same container
with a command, java -version.
And we see that we've got Java 8
installed inside the container.
If I run the same command on my
machine, I've got only Java 7.
So this is to show you that
you can use different versions.
ALEXIS MP: They're
completely isolated.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yes, completely.
So now we can try to run
the real applications
by letting the container
use the default command.
And here it is.
Our website is running.
Yeah.
ALEXIS MP: So you build
all of this locally
and you have something
that's working.
So now we can ship
it-- that's probably
the best way to describe
it-- to the cloud.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yes.
Just before, let's
try to open it
into a brother to make sure
that it works property.
So we're going to run
the container-- Oh.
What's going on is I've got
other containers running
on the same port.
So I'm going to delete
all my running containers.
It's like deleting
running processes.
I just kill them, and
then run my process again.
And now it's running as a
daemon in the background.
So we open a URL and see that
the site is running properly.
Yes.
ALEXIS MP: That's great.
Perfect.
DAVID GAGEOT: As you
say, now let's ship it.
So we're going to
ship it to deploy it
on Google Compute Engine.
So we're going to open the
Google Compute Engine console.
And we're going to create
a VM on which we're
going to install Docker.
And then we're going to
build the same container
from the same recipe.
ALEXIS MP: So we're really
starting from scratch.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yes, from scratch.
Choose the name,
allow HTTP traffic.
Choose the zone of our VM.
We can choose among
different type of machines.
I'll keep the default one.
I'm going to choose a
Debian from my machine.
So everything I do
here on website,
I could do through the
API with a command line.
Here it is.
Here's the command line
you could run to do it.
ALEXIS MP: Especially
if you want
to instantiate multiple VMs
with the same configuration.
DAVID GAGEOT: What I
like about Google Cloud
platform is I can
always click on a link
to show me the command I'm going
to execute from the website.
That's nice.
So I can see that
the VM is created.
That was quick.
And I'm going to SSH into the
VM using the command given
by the website.
I could use a standard SSH,
it's just that here there's
a wrapper that uses the
correct configuration, security
configuration mainly.
We have to wait
for the VM to boot.
ALEXIS MP: Shouldn't
take too long.
DAVID GAGEOT: Here it is.
Yes.
So I'm in the machine.
Maybe 15 seconds to make it run.
Docker is not installed.
I'm going to install Docker.
So it takes about 20 seconds.
I need to [INAUDIBLE] the line
to install it on the machine.
ALEXIS MP: Yeah, it's
probably interesting to see
how it's being
installed, but there
are other options
where it comes, maybe,
packaged as part of the image.
DAVID GAGEOT: I could
package it myself.
I can install it on Google Base
image and create a new image.
Or I could use the
images provided
by Google that already
have Docker installed.
So I've got lots of options.
Here it will download
Docker, install it,
make sure it works properly.
OK, docker was installed.
It started, and now--
ALEXIS MP: It's going through
a few tests, just to make sure.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yes.
It will run a basic container
to make sure it works property.
Then I have to add the
current user to the dock group
to make sure I can run
Docker without sudo.
Here it is.
Let's run docker ps
to see what's running.
Nothing, normal.
So I'm going to build the same
image from the same recipe.
This time the recipe is
not locally on my machine,
it was published on Github.
So I'll just give
the URL to Github.
And the Dockerfile will
be downloaded and used
to build a container.
And so I will see the exact
same step on my local machine.
It will download it
too, install Java 8,
extract and build
the application.
It will be ready to run.
ALEXIS MP: Yeah,
so maybe a little
bit faster, because the
network is somewhat faster.
But other than that,
it's very similar.
So we'll skip ahead
and get to the point
where it's almost ready
to finish building.
DAVID GAGEOT: Here it is.
So the build is running.
And done.
The container is ready to run.
So let's make sure
that it runs properly.
We'll use the docker
run command again.
ALEXIS MP: So it happens to
be the exact same command,
but you could map it
to a different port
if you wanted to.
DAVID GAGEOT: Same version
of Java as on my machine.
And then I can run the real web
application in the background.
Done.
And I can check that
everything is running properly
by opening the IP of
my VM, and it works.
ALEXIS MP: Great.
So we've successfully shipped
something from the laptop
to the cloud, and
it behaves exactly
in the same way, which is what
we were trying to demonstrate.
That's a good thing.
Great, so that worked.
That's very good.
We were trying to
demonstrate something.
Shipping, building, and
behaving the exact same way
on both environments.
And you can have that on
many different environments.
So, by the way, you
were doing a demo
on Mac, which required
a little bit of setup.
You want to--
DAVID GAGEOT: Yes.
It uses a component
called Boot2docker.
Boot2docker is a
very lightweight VM
that is running Linux.
And it is used to run the
Docker daemon on my laptop.
On the Google Cloud
platform, this
is Debian, so it's
running natively.
But on my machine, it's the
only way to make it run.
ALEXIS MP: Great, so that
was very interesting.
One key element, obviously,
here is the Dockerfile itself,
which is somewhat of the recipe.
Who writes the Dockerfile,
in your experience?
Who should write it?
DAVID GAGEOT: I think
that it's mainly
the developer that
writes the Dockerfile.
But you've seen on
Dockerfile that you
can base your Dockerfile
from another container.
So this container
is base container.
It could be [INAUDIBLE],
Ubuntu, or Debian.
Or it could be a base
container that you
developed with an operation.
So you choose a base container
for all your applications,
and then the developer
writes the Dockerfile
for each application.
ALEXIS MP: Great.
So would you recommend
using Docker today?
On development environment,
on production environment,
maybe on Compute
Engine, specifically?
DAVID GAGEOT: I do it
every day for my customers.
There's a lot of big companies
using Docker already.
So it's really a production
ready, so try it.
Give it a try, and
you'll be happy, I think.
ALEXIS MP: And try
it for yourself.
You've probably heard
of Docker before.
Now is a good time
to try, and you
could do this on
the Cloud platform,
and Compute Engine,
specifically,
following something similar
to what David showed us today.
So thank you, David.
DAVID GAGEOT: Thank you.
ALEXIS MP: Thanks for coming,
and I'll be seeing you soon.
Cheers.